thanks for being here today I came to
CMS in the fall of 2015 with the
intention of making the presidential
election the focus of my thesis and in
the most basic sense that is what I did
in this study and what we presented
today but if you could have predicted in
advance just hop tumultuous
transformative and for many of us
disheartening in the election who would
end up being of course you can only put
some in 200 pages in 20 minutes and so
they're a huge and important aspects of
the election that won't get much
mentioned today including the disturbing
rise of big news evasion boredom in the
election by foreign actors and the
failure of posters to predict the
outcome any which by themselves are
concerning constituted pieces but what I
present today nonetheless have
implications I think at least implicitly
for these other questions in my thesis
have a offer an overview of the flows of
communication between candidates voters
in the media over the course of the
campaign in particular I explained how
this new new communication ecosystem was
especially beneficial to Donald Trump
charismatic candidate purporting to be
an outsider who journalists and paranoid
tropes in his campaign at the center of
his communication strategy as I will
show is a social network Twitter and as
president Donald Trump's use of Twitter
continues to dominate the news agenda
providing a powerful personal outlet and
the most powerful person before he turns
to the 27th 2016 campaign are going to
choose a concept paranoid person and two
figures for 20th century in American
history were bullied it in their
Viennese paranoid populism is the
shorthand I use a combination of two
related but distinct either ideological
constructs
populism and political Paraguay as we'll
see paranoid populism as I render it was
a useful lens through which to view the
trunk
you see and as a way to understand that
even start to explain her success
although populism in American politics
has eluded precise definition scholar
scholars nonetheless agree on several
over several of his characteristics as
his name suggests populism proposed to
advocate for the people though in truth
populist specifically revered for
ordinary people or what my peasant dubs
a noble assemblage in fact may be more
appropriate to refer to not to a group
of people but to a place Paul Taylor
calls the hotline populism is to find
moreover in its opposition to a selfish
choice to leave unconnected and
unconcerned with a plate of the moment
these appeals the pure ordering
Heartland in contrast to an elite as a
cosmopolitanism is corrupt it always
invariably stoke economic resentment as
well as cultural and tagging see given
the subjection to coastal deletes
populist movements typically spearheaded
by a figure with outsider credentials
especially someone with charismatic
communication abilities who tells it
like it is one final feature typically
associated with optimism is that it is
manifested in the communication
strategies nervous leaders as a
conscious rhetorical project by thus
argue that Donald Trump's use of Twitter
as an unfiltered means of communication
was the essence of this process appeal
the populism alone is not fully
encapsulating the candidacy at all
we also need to consider what I call
paranoia a consideration here should be
considered in a political rather than
the clinical sense
Brigitte Hofstadter's influential essay
1964 the paranoid style and American
politics provides insightful look at the
appeal of this train of thinking and its
impact post artists essay written amidst
the rise of foreign Republican candidate
Barry Goldwater pinpoints three
characteristics exaggeration suspicion
and conspiratorial fantasy which he says
constitute paranoia populism paranoia is
an ideological construct targeting seven
sets of people chief among them
according to Daniel Pipes both the
politically disaffected and a culturally
suspicious paranoid thinking shares much
with populist ideology notley's us
versus them mentality distrustful the
beliefs its appeal of like that of
populism can be accepted by media
technology in 1964 of star they noted
that the crew villains today are much
more vivid than those that are currently
princesses yet the two terms are not
entirely overlaps politicians famous for
them into communist paranoia including
Goldwater and Joseph Bhavani we're not
over populist politics and McCartney
Carthy was felled by its own Latin
prisoner when combined for a populist
ideology and paranoid thinking can prove
powerful especially when enabled by the
meteor of the day two figures from 20th
century American history Charles
Coughlin and Pat Robertson both employee
paranoid topless tropes and taxes in
their quest to fill of dedicated
audiences on emerging communications
platforms and their stories are
therefore constructed
it's possible Michelle - writes that no
single individual have more
in fact I'm thinking about the radio
audience the Charles problem ordained as
a Catholic priest from 1916 Coggan began
a regular radio broadcast from 1926 the
time when the medium was in its infancy
his sermons initially focused on narrow
a religious man that matters but became
a retaining almost exclusively political
in concept common employee a wide
variety of rhetorical techniques and a
folksy way of address to appeal to the
matter the street Coggins audience was
drawn to his coverage of America's deep
financial depression and the blame that
gear stroke for this to the industrial
elite as well as the Roosevelt
administration in so doing prominent
tapped into an inflexible communication
platform around which funerals or rules
have been established he initially
enjoyed easy access to his audience
through an independent system of radio
stations which broadcast his sermons
meaning in essence the deform station
objected to his content it could simply
strike a deal with a rival cognate
audience peaked at a remarkable 16
million in 1930 games giving rise to the
possibly apocryphal nation that hearing
his voice out of every window you could
walk the blocks and never miss a word if
Cullen's large audience would not prove
internal a combination of religious
political and media elites
ultimately conspired to take him off the
air as more radio stations eventually
turn guests in the outbreak of the
Second World War which problem have been
the loopers joining saw a new limits
placed on controversial public issues
one of the precedents to the Fairness
Doctrine which would be introduced in
1949 before this for members coming in
anomalous demonstrated the appeal of
paranoid populism and its ability to
thrive on a new communicate
at least while political and market
conditions were favorable and hopeful
regulation Dakota Commons experience
brings to mind another paranoid populist
firebrand parallelism who also utilized
the emerging medium to build a similar
loyal if narrower following roses
Christian Broadcasting Network launched
in 1961 broadcasters programming by
satellite making his religious messaging
seemingly descended from the heavens
Providence movement set itself against
the perceived liberal excesses of the
1960's appealing to the more traditional
values of ordinary folk in his
broadcasts Robinson seize the mantle of
evangelical conspiracy and those from
the tradition of prophecy theology which
predicted an imminent Second Coming
prefigured by of processes including
drugs from the Bulls this unmediated
Christian perspective was made possible
through CBN satellite transmission
system as well as by changes in
regulation which may have religious
broadcasting technically and
economically infeasible CBN was
eventually available to 3,000 cable
systems and the number of Americans view
in Britain is programming rose from
around 5 million in the late 60s to
about 25 million in the mid-80s
BRABUS media success spread political
ambitions to do and ultimately struggled
to prove on his base and he failed to
win a single state when he ran in the
and presidential primary in 1988 if he
goes only in such a fellow at 52% during
its presidential run
amongst other reasons it seems that his
attempts to go mainstream and secure the
widest place of the Republican
electorate needed for the nomination
forced him into more specific political
pronouncements many altered the space
the expenses of Charles Coleman and
pepper herbs and dipper but share some
characteristics both were paranoid
populist who exploited emerging media
technology before me the rivals or
regulations we capture political factors
for calming the Second World War and for
Robertson the realities of majoritarian
politics also eventually hampered their
ambitions but viewed in another way each
had bore the element Lance
Coleman's platform was broad with shaky
rip from others piqued by regulations
and nervous networks Robinson's audience
was deep and narrow and he was unable to
prominent to encompass a wide array the
voters when he ran for president it
seems there that any paranoid populist
seeking prominence and public office
he's a hybrid communication structure
with both a direct unfiltered platform
and the ability to get noticed by a much
wider audience
which brings us to Donald Trump I
wouldn't spend much time here rehashing
the story of the 2016 presidential
election since it remains of the sweet
fresh in everyone's mind but it is worth
remembering at the outset several of the
perceived weaknesses of Trump's
candidacy when he started he was up
against 16 other Republican presidential
candidates the largest field in history
which meant that before any votes were
even cast endorsements fundraising and
media attention were in high demand
intensified endorsements and fundraising
Trump with minimal support inside the
GOP and little organization was running
the world of mind
campaign filings in January 2016 on the
eve of the first primaries and offer
some candidates but already dropped out
show Trump running only fourth
thunderation estates well even by the
time trample each denomination the
important the nomination may airwave
disliked in the party sitting in fourth
on rankings of active republican
officials endorsements as I see the
Trump the metric that did dominate was
media attention in this respect Trump
had several inbuild advantages including
decades of experience dealing with the
media premiering a couple of newspapers
and his views hosting NBC's apprentice
show Trump also had a Twitter account
said Obama in 2009 under the handle of
Admiral Donald Trump which reached
several million followers at the outset
his campaign and for the past several
years Trump was the informal speak and
full chief spokesperson of the birther
movement a group that falsely alleged
the President Barack Obama have been
born outside the United States and was
thus eligible to serve Trump in other
words knew how to get attention in large
part by saying and doing in our
interstates and in its early stages his
campaign was treated as a joke with
traditional website 5:30 a variety of
his chances and the huffington post news
website deciding to cover Trump's
campaign in its entertainment section
yet on the trail and on Twitter
Trump's campaign began to gather steam
and it appears in both domains Trump
embrace the tropes of a paranoid
populist in a matter of those who came
before I run the text of all of Trump's
tweets through callers an aversive
software to determine his most common
words and phrases as you might expect
his slogan make America great again was
one of his favorite hashtags during the
primaries his chart shows coming up 286
time to overall
that's for one in every trivet words of
treatment the phrase perfectly
encapsulates the paranoid populism as
defined earlier and is evidence that
Trump's campaign to deliberately
targeting targeting disaffected poodles
many people respond to the slogan by
ousting war web exactly in Trump's
estimation of walls of America great
trout managed to avoid being pinned down
on this question directly during the
campaign but his store attacks on the
legitimacy and record of Barack Obama
become his first african-american
American president opportunity by
simultaneously alleging that American
seemingly lost his greatness and by
pinpointing the country's first black
president as the chief agent in this
process of perceive decline Trevor was
making a very bit very particularly
appeal to America's heart as noted
earlier by replacing the people that say
with the Heartland populace can restrict
the scope that their appeals to citizens
deemed culturally and racially ordinary
through his slogan and other campaign
pronouncements Trump tapped a vein of
American normalcy which stretched back
centuries
seeking to restricted scope to become
his Heartland and implicitly
than into a particular kind of cultural
and regional graceful the Germany
turning to be a general election against
very Clinton Trump on Twitter to fight
the traditional migration to the center
ground to double down on his paranoid
populist rhetoric as this graph shows
make America great again
emerges from such attack during the
German his second and third most popular
phrases were America first afraid of the
long history of isolationism tainted
with mental Semitism and drain the swamp
another classically populist
and he elitist sentiment referring to
Washington bureaucrats given in addition
so the key was from said it's also
instructive to look at how to use the
platform Trump began the campaign with
almost three million followers and they
learned 30 million by an election age
but linear growth in his following this
is an impressive number for any
politician not named Barack Obama and in
an inner self partially explains Trump's
prodigiously tweeting throughout the
campaign Twitter though is a fainting
messaging network Riven with bots trolls
and much else
so does reasonable to assume that Trump
was reaching far fewer than the three or
thirty million doses each time he
tweeted one of the strengths of Twitter
though instead of the potential for
clarification
it's built into its architecture through
its retweet functionality that's such
essentially possible to analyze the
amount of wider reach the Trump's tweets
received during the campaign
so for each month I calculated the
number of the average number of retweets
that each tweet received as trend as you
can see the amount of magnification that
Trump received in his tweets first
consider over the course of the campaign
from an average of only 200 retweets at
the outset so there were 12,000 for
tweets sent in October 2016 the last
month campaign this effect mostly hold
even when we control for his rising
number of followers across the period
trouble crossed over the campaign with a
base of followers for an excess of the
average presidential candidate
this should disabuse any notion the
Trump letter campaign from the virtual
grassroots is in fact a true high levels
of name recognition for many years but
what you did to was utilize his existing
following into a source of much wider
exposure both for the paranoid populist
message and employed both on Twitter and
beyond and yet as Trump appears to
intuit it reaching several million
followers or even several million more
through retweets wasn't enough he also
needed to establish as much exposure as
possible in the mainstream media another
pilot Twitter's architecture is the
acrid life which links your own tweets
to the account of some of the outs are
using the app key as this chart shows in
his most in the most common use of group
amplifies trumps all attention from
predominately media sources with a
couple of exceptions in the primary this
Muslim immediately somewhat sympathetic
to his campaign focus news channel in
the general election however Trump's
media diet appears to have evolved to
include centrist sources like CNN and
the New York Times yet to a greater
extent than in the primary terms
references to the media are around more
than simply increasing his exposure of
his 38 references to the times for
example fully 25 were to quote were to
be quite failing New York Times this
Jess an evolution in drama strategy
Trump's tweets during the generations
seem to have had less to do with
highlighting his media experiences and
Walter reading appearances and more to
do with objecting to unfavorable
coverage by seeking 50 was
I see organizations providing this Trump
used Twitter to both deploy paranoid
botanist troops and the target media
sources seeking both attention and
retribution for perceived criticism it
seems as it seems to evoke something of
a hybrid between strategy stoking the
small of committed base of followers to
redirect
unmediated slew of messages and reaching
out
however angrily to try to gain a
foothold in the mainstream media for
those whom Trump was reaching directly
with furious Twitter accounts we your
exposure presumably did not affect their
support one way or the other but the
larger bulk of prospective voters whose
support is sort Trump required if not
the support of them then at least an
interested mainstream media of course
Trump is not the first candidate ever to
seek media exposure the decades
companies are trying to find cheap and
efficient ways to get through the
media's gatekeeping process which
restricts the flow of information to the
public in the past everything from press
releases to photo ops have been used by
campaigns to try to seize the media
spotlight if it works this can result in
free media as opposed to expensive TV
ads another theory of theoretical
concept is useful yet they're thinking
about how the media covers the news in a
book about the Vietnam War then you know
how I've introduced three spheres of
political discourse in America first
there is a sphere of consensus amplify
issues about which most everyone agrees
and for which an opposing viewpoint
doesn't not need to be presented the
second spirit is that all legitimate
controversy this contains issues of the
region recently disagreed about such as
whether marijuana should be legal
the third sphere is a true sphere of
deviance issues so outside the
mainstream the journalists condemn them
such as heinous crime and points for
anyone who gets
yeah there are two country tourism two
things to consider about Holland spheres
first they are permeable issues can move
between you over time consider for
example attitudes towards women's
suffrage between the 19th century of
today and second studies show that
journalists disproportionately choose to
cover deviants even as they condemn over
the course of the campaign Donald Trump
made myriad deviant statements in many
cases there were no shortage of people
decrying them as abnormal or wrong the
doodle is also true that the sheer
interest in Trump's campaign often
outweigh concerns about confirmation in
an interview at Harvard on the eve of
the election CNN President Jeff Zucker
expressed regret for the hours upon
hours of life unfiltered footage of
Trump's rallies that his networks
network for organized of course this
covered is an enormous ratings hit and
another consideration which undoubtedly
contributed to the network's decisions
but without a filter of condemnation as
coverage so to normalize it even hugest
- Trump's candidacy my analysis suggests
that Trump's deviance on Twitter meant
his account was also over covered with
respect to other candidates fire
research Macquarie's media cloud
database developed by MIT senate pacific
media but the twitter handle's of each
of the republican candidates over the
course of the primary as this graph
shows even the mainstream media
references to real Donald Trump were far
access to the Twitter handles of his
rivals who barely kept looking of course
correlation between Trump's deviants and
the disproportionate coverage is to
explode doesn't prove a causal
relationship and many of these
references to Trump's Twitter were
presumably condemned again but it
nevertheless says a lot that Trump's
paranoid plotless tweeting received so
much mainstream coverage during the
primary election at a time when me your
attention contributed considerably to
account alerts viability and so what am
i saying today first the Trump's
campaign contain many of the Peron
populist tropes of his ideological
forebears and that much of this ideology
manifested itself in his communication
strategy which was abnormally focused on
Twitter second and rated that Twitter
offer trump a direct unfiltered lines in
his base of committed supporters sending
messages which were amplified by them
through the network and finally the
Trump who baked familiar attention even
his even the submerged outlets which
provided it succeeded in getting through
the gatekeepers in large part because of
the deviance of his paranoid popular
status thus Trump needed the loyal
following melded the loyal following of
Pat Robinson with a broad appeal of
public comment to become America's first
Paralympic as president every election
is decided by a myriad of factors but in
the case of 2016 my research suggests
that without real Donald Trump we
wouldn't have President Donald Trump
thanks for listening I hope your
questions and if you want to discuss
this any further later
[Applause]
that's a very like nice and tidy line of
the partner hug with style education
ship to new media forums and you're
facing some a go to side like that and I
guess I'm just wondering why should we
be convinced of the importance of
Twitter it's just one campaign it's a
nice maybe I've done it's a little bit
too neat in other words if we could
imagine a Donald Trump campaign without
Twitter we could say you know the
primary amplifier is paranoid cyclist
rhetorical protis was Fox News is
forgiving satellite radio is still but
we might think about when you know an
intentional across media strategy where
he's very aware every week is going to
be covered by mainstream media Hearst
and Twitter is playing some type of role
but not necessarily yeah so what why
should we be convinced that it's of
central elements and a part of the part
of the question is about the very low
use of Twitter broader population and I
don't know but I'm curious if you looked
at sort of Twitter use rates among the
Trump
and Twitter is something that's used by
a younger wealthier and more coastal
demographic that may have shifted
because a business oh sure yeah that's
absolutely right and I'm definitely
clear about the fact that trauma so
stretchy was across reading it right so
it certainly was being boosted by the
other toll-free yeah the Fox News
example is a little more conservative
Pat Kelly
and for a while it looked like they were
going to not cover him as favorably or
them at all as we'd like so I think the
emphasis on Twitter while definitely a
little too tiny is just to emphasize the
unmediated quality of that I think
that's something which plays upon them
and robust and well they have their
audience in the place were able to
exploit for them to basically say
whatever he wanted what he was giving a
seventh eventually tripped off like that
and so I think Twitter is not unique at
least very interesting and instrumental
in so far as it was very money mediated
life to his to his public and even if it
was employed the sole focus of the
photos themselves they were being you
know federal of this stuff by the media
to boot a lot of it in M&A from putting
incredible cervicals at the end
another way to think about what clashes
point to is that we assume that the
value of Twitter is that the truck reach
all the supporters directly everything
right but if the reality is that well
actually it'd be just more educated way
everybody for whatever it doesn't matter
because those people run Fox News on CNN
and so on and so that you could say that
Twitter's value seems to be reaching a
mass audience them directly but its
value really maybe just be able to shape
the news events every day because you
know and seizing the news cycle yeah and
that's going to be kind of maybe make
interpretations of us I think trumpeters
candidate was fascinating to study now I
think it's kind of imperative as a
trumpets president particularly given
that he can go online and tweet news
agenda agenda setting is a phrase that I
couldn't find a route from this
presentation that sending pears my
thesis I think I try to elucidate that
as you think of their kind of two-step
flow between candidate to media to
voters of course there are several hours
with synchronous it so review there's an
arrow from voters to Twitter which is
very important as an arrow from the
media to trumpet and be one of the
raging things now is do we have an echo
chamber between Fox News wants to talk
about and tweets about and then fox news
reports now which is if anything scary
more work but it would certainly
campaign the friction with Fox News was
the reason think about well and just
please just
hypothesizing already on both what Sasha
and Heather said I mean maybe Twitter
was actually his unmediated lying to the
media in the sense that as you mentioned
like he was originally running a very
lean campaign
I didn't have a lot of money they
weren't running a lot of ads and you
know this in conjunction with his calls
and you know CNN coverage and all that
might have been whisper very smart like
business decision to reach directly to
influencers and media outlets who he
knew would reliably amplify a message
tuna face yeah I'm still at times when
folks he's wasn't learning on the air or
CNN systemically nasty that seem to be
the place where he went and it seemed to
do a useful job in allowing you to read
the terms of
Howie
did you repeat the question for the
lights being yeah so the question is
basically do we think about and if so
how should we think about using Twitter
as a regulation Twitter to try to
prevent in this this stuff you know I
think really the responsibility probably
falls on the journalists because the
instrument control I think taking it I
think if I think Trump now possibly come
in 20 percent each from now is powerful
enough that if Jack Dorsey decided to
ban him then there would be you know
simply set of his own he would find them
now you find fi an unmediated waiting to
talk to public so I think it kind of
kicking off Twitter as satisfying that
would be probably wouldn't achieve too
much but I think so the journalists and
others can be kind of banal be
interesting but not agree with you never
going to think that the tiny effect
which adds up to the big effect of
amplification Genesis
[Applause]
with technology against receipt well my
head setting up judge can you say
something about that right part right
Bart news i'm batman and was it like you
know that the media team recently did an
analysis come yes Pierre